Speaker 1: All right, let's check in on the
Herschel Walker campaign. Herschel Walker is the
Republican Senate candidate in Georgia. Herschel
Walker knows very little about anything. He had
a debate last week during which he flashed a
fake badge. He claims to be a police officer.
He claims to have trained with the FBI. He
has been credibly accused of paying for an
ex-girlfriend's abortion and urging her to have a
second abortion despite claiming to be vehemently
pro-life against abortion. Abortion is murder, no
exceptions whatsoever, except he has paid for a
woman's abortion. We are continuing to follow the
breakdown of any semblance of truth and reality
from Herschel Walker. So let's go through piece
by piece. First and foremost, he was interviewed.
Herschel Walker was interviewed by NBC News. And
in this NBC News interview, he continues to claim,
no, I never paid for anyone's abortion. And the
explanation that he gives in this clip suggests
either he doesn't know how many or which children
he has that's possible, or you have to believe in
time travel for this explanation to make sense.
So let me set it up for you. Herschel Walker's new
denial is okay, fine. I do know the woman who
says I paid for her to get an abortion. After
urging her to get an abortion, I did send her a
$700 check, but I sent her the $700 check for the
child we have together. The only problem is the
check was sent years before that child was born.
So is it a case of time travel? Did
Herschel Walker travel back in time
to give her the money for a kid that would be
born years later? I don't know. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: This is still alive because she's
the mother of my child. So you're going to see
somebody giving a check. So I'm saying this a lot.
Speaker 2: Do you know what this $700?
Speaker 3: I have no idea what that can be for.
Speaker 2: Is that your signature?
Speaker 3: Oh, no. It could be.
And it doesn't matter whether it's
my signature or not. Is this my check?
Speaker 1: Yep. Okay. So, yes, it's my
my signature. Yes. I sent $700 to this woman.
Yes, I do know the woman. Despite previously
playing dumb about it. Until you no longer could.
Because she's the mother of one of your children.
The money was because we have a child together.
But that child did not exist at the time that
he sent the $700 check. Now, in Herschel Walker's
defense. If I understand the timeline, he did have
a different kid with a different woman that very
same year. It's possible that he's confused about
which woman he sent the $700 to. I don't know.
The other possibility is that Walker is confusing
children that he has. I just don't know. And it is
quite stunning how many media outlets continue to
accept these bogus explanations without doing the
just fundamental math. It's not even really math.
It's just understanding time. And that time moves
forward as far as we understand it right now,
and that the timing completely debunks these
completely bogus stories. And unfortunately,
almost everybody is kind of treating
him with kid gloves on this. Even
during the debate last week with
Raphael Warnock, as I told you,
one of the worst moderated debates I've ever
seen. The moderators not pressing at all just,
oh, the story is untrue. But. Right. Well, he
says it's untrue. Well, but hold on a second.
Is the woman in question, the mother of one of
your children? Well, yeah. So you do know the
woman? Yes. And you were dating her at the time
that she claims you paid for her abortion? Well,
yeah, I guess I was. And is it possible that she
became pregnant due to someone else's doing well?
No. They could easily break this down and get to
the bottom of it very, very quickly. But they can
continue to treat him with kid gloves. And it is
abundantly clear at this point that he is lying